dr. Atul Gawande help transform the
conversation about Aging in his book
being mortal medicine and what matters
in the end his book was on the New York
Times bestseller list for 85 weeks it
spent eight weeks at number one and is
now available in paperback dr. Gawande
is a professor at Harvard Medical School
he is also a surgeon at Brigham and
Women's Hospital in Boston dr. Gawande
so good to see you glad to be here this
we were discussing this before the show
with everything else that's happening no
matter when the subject comes up it
always prompts a big discussion how do
you think the conversation about
end-of-life has changed since this book
came out I think the big thing that's
changed is that people are getting the
idea that this isn't about death panels
this isn't about are you gonna give up
this is about what are you fighting for
people turn out to have priorities in
their life besides just living longer we
need to ask people what their priorities
are especially when they have a serious
illness or frailty if we don't ask our
care and what we do to people isn't
aligned with what they what matters most
of them and then you get suffering but
when you do ask it's extraordinary and
people are just now they're starting to
ask words matter like what I mean it
really got me thinking about how I want
to die when I want to die even though I
have no sale but you know it made me
think what is the best way to in your
life and it's not what way what is the
best way for life to end rather and you
said it's not about the quality it is
more about the quality not the quantity
of the life yeah here's the important
thing this book it seems like they're
really scary right yeah how do you have
a good death that is not the goal the
goal is not a good death the goal is a
good life all the way to the very end
which in the asking yeah yeah so what
you have to ask are things like what's
your understanding of where you are with
your health what are you willing to go
through and what are you not willing to
go through for the sake of more time
what's the minimum quality of life you'd
find acceptable what are your fears what
about what's ahead with your health and
people then say I've read about a man
who said his answer was well if I can
watch football on television any
chocolate ice cream
that'll be good enough for me keep me
going and I don't like anything to do
that I'll go through anything do it
if I can't let me go it's it's the best
living will ever and then you start
asking well would that be good enough
for you go would that be good enough for
you
and the conversation starts I like how
you've reframed this debate and about
how in medical school the whole thing is
about how to save lives but we don't
talk about the demise of life how
important is that not only from a
financial perspective in terms of
Medicare but from a moral perspective
yeah I mean I think what definitely
starts the conversation sometimes on the
public stage is we spend a quarter of
all Medicare dollars on the last year of
life most of it in the last couple
months and it's often the evidences it's
often increasing suffering rather than
improving life but the real moral
question is getting to that focus on how
do you want to live what really matters
to you and we don't ask that question I
tell the story of a medical director in
the nursing home who fought a battle to
allow people to have pets in the nursing
home there was a fight with the staff
there was a fight with the director
there's the fight with the regulator's
because they all say well it's not safe
but life is bigger than safety and
survival it do I have love in my life
which the pets brought do I have
responsibility do I have something to
care for and so the people actually had
lower drug use and they lived longer
well you say most people want to fight
til the bitter end until they're told
that where the doctors say there's
nothing more we can do which is really
not a good way to look at it that's how
I've looked at not a good way to look at
it because there's always something
doctors can do we can always call
anymore but at what cost
yeah and the the real question is not do
you fight or do you want to give up what
are you fighting for my father I tell
the story surgeon had a brain tumor and
then when we asked what are you really
fighting for for him it wasn't chocolate
ice cream and football on television it
was to be at the family dinner table
with family and friends and be able to
enjoy that experience at least some of
the time and so then we could we could
guide around the fact that if he lost
that that's when just make sure he's not
in pain here's a little nugget for you
to have children chances of avoiding a
nursing home directly related to the
number of children you have especially
if you have daughters
thank you doctor thank you thank you
thank you